last night a mouse got into the van at
3:00 in the
morning
and got it out but today I was working
on my computer and I looked over to my
right and there was another Mouse
sticking its head out from up here and
haven't gotten that one out
[Music]
yet I didn't get any sleep last night
and I seriously doubt I'll get any sleep
tonight I'm just going to leave which
really sucks because this is literally
such a beautiful beautiful campsite I
wanted to shoot sunset tonight and take
some photos and stuff but it's just not
worth it they can do some real damage
this little tiny Mouse last night left
droppings like all under my bed which
really freaks me out cuz I was sleeping
there I don't know if he hopped up on
top of my covers I don't know if you
guys have any advice on like where
exactly entry points are in a ram proas
for mice please let me know because I
need to fix that ASAP
so little update I just tried to get the
mouse out for like 45 minutes I drove
down a really gnarly Road and went to
The Visitor Center opened up all the
doors pounded on this up here cuz that's
where I last saw it Po's H little head
out and still can hear it scurrying
around so still in there super
frustrating hopefully there's only one
this is the second mouse in 24 hours
there's a chance there's more which I'm
really terrified of
but um so my plan tonight was to shoot
Sunset I had like this whole shot list I
wanted to do was super excited for and
then finish editing a YouTube video
uploaded tonight and post it tomorrow
morning instead I had to do a conference
call which unexpectedly ate up all my
hot spot for internet and I only have
like 10% left but I still have half the
month so it's not enough to upload a
YouTube video and then this mouse
situation so so here I am driving to
Colorado I don't
know I'm leaving and uh just want to
highlight
how in this lifestyle you can make a
plan and next thing you know you'll be
on the road to another
state it's just the way it goes
[Music]
sometimes
w
I have
removed three mice at this point and I
can still hear another one potentially
two CU it's uh it's pretty
loud
so I built a little barricade hoping
that the mouse won't jump up on my bed
when I'm
sleeping
for
[Music]
now
yesterday I decided to Camp outside for
the night in a tent
because honestly I just couldn't handle
another night of hearing little
scratches and pitter patter across the
floor this morning I am still hearing
little scratched sounds but admittedly
not nearly as bad as the last two days I
think they're might be one Mouse left I
have found four I think a whole family
of mice moved in when I was staying in
the Tetons I caught three in traps and
one I pulled over in the middle of the
night on the drive and um put a little
piece of cheese outside put a headlamp
on it and sure enough this little mouse
went crawling out to the cheese so I
just took off like peeled out of the
parking lot at this point what I have
tried and done is doused the van and
peppermint oil honestly the smell is so
overwhelming still I also strategically
place dryer sheets all throughout the
van and I have one of those little
electronic devices that is supposed to
be like a rodent repellent um and I put
that under the engine I put shavings of
Irish Spring soap around around all the
tires and cayenne pepper My Hope Is that
tonight they will evacuate I don't know
if what coming across over camera just
how maddening this is I've not had a
mouse in my vehicle in all the time that
I've lived on the road and for it to
happen after just getting everything
rebuilt and like pouring so much energy
into this it's a little disheartening
yeah and it's super maddening because
they can be so damaging they can chew up
the engine bay wires they can chew up
the wiring to the solar and throughout
the van they can get up and Behind the
Walls worse than that they could crawl
into some like unreachable place and
die which is sad and also smelly van
life is kind of not working out at the
moment uh but trying to keep a positive
attitude trying trying to do everything
possible oh I also forgot to mention on
the drive over here uh I was on a
highway where I didn't see vehicles
coming in either direction so I pulled
off opened up all the doors and laid on
the horn like several
[Music]
times
so if that didn't
work I don't know I don't know what else
to do so yeah that's that's where we're
at so cool dinosaur
track
Love's going to make us going to make
us
[Music]
I got in blind
SP I got him on blind
spot I swear I gave him
on I
got
[Music]
oh
looks like a decent
spot Risky Business oh my almost H tree
okay
oh